If you're doing more than just watching these lectures, one of the things
you're going to be staring at a lot is the Business Model Canvas.
If you're watching this video, the first thing I suggest is stop, go to businessmodelgeneration.com,
and download the canvas and print out bunch of copies.
Then go get a bunch of yellow stickies and a red pen because that's what
you're going to be using for the next couple of weeks.
Now, what we actually do with the Business Model Canvas is in week 1.
You use those yellow stickies to put up all your hypotheses
and you probably don't have many facts yet but you can make some pretty good guesses about
what's a value prop, where the customers are, what your channel is and what your pricing is,
but what more can they do is really interesting.
It's as you come back in with facts, we're going to be marking up the canvas
and crossing out the things that actually weren't true and replacing them with the things we've learned,
and we're going to do that week after week until what we end up with
is a step of Business Model Canvases, and what you'll find out is at the end of the class,
you can actually play back these canvases almost like a filmstrip
and see what you've learned overtime.